comme adolescente florence tremblay
gagnon a été suivie à l'hôpital sainte
justine pour des troubles alimentaires
elle ne s'étonne pas des problèmes
déclenchée par l' isolement au printemps
2020 quand je pense à la aux adolescents
se sont retrouvés tous seuls avec leur
bébé est qu en eux la vulnérabilité du
trouble alimentaire mais on va chercher
un moyen compte de l'impression d'avoir
le contrôle de notre alimentation c'est
le sport si si même si au fond on perd
le contrôle en réellement on ne peut le
contrôler absolument pas mais c'est
comme ce qu'on sait le nombre
d'adolescentes hospitalisés pour des
troubles alimentaires a bondi de 60%
depuis le début de la pandémie selon une
étude de l'institut canadien
d'information sur la santé
le soir on % étaient chez les filles
principalement de 10 à 17 ans dont une
jeune femme par exemple pourraient avoir
pris du poids pendant la pandémie et
vinoy or perdre du poids de façon
malsaine de façon drastique qu'elle
s'assoit en se rasant gromellon prenant
des axes actif la même augmentation a
été mesurée au chu sainte justine avec
trois pics d'hospitalisation au cours
des deux dernières années une
augmentation divisé en clinique externe
et aussi des cas les plus graves on n'a
pas vu venir puis ça a commencé assez
vite dès le mois de mai 2020 on a vu
quelque chose qui se passait avec
l'augmentation des troubles alimentaires
de nouveaux maintenant depuis le mois de
janvier on est encore dans une phase où
il ya beaucoup de jeunes malheureusement
qui viennent à voir avec des problèmes
de cet ordre là donc vraiment ça n'a pas
dérougi je dirais les hospitalisations
sont encore nombreuses on tourne peu
près autour de 16 18 patients
hospitalisés alors qu'on devrait tourner
plutôt autour de 10 12 et ce n'est pas
que chez les jeunes patients l'hôpital
douglas de montréal a vu bondir le
nombre de cas également l'autre grand
nombre de personnes atteintes d'un
trouble de l'alimentation ont l'âge
adulte aussi je peux dire que notre le
nombre de requêtes pour de l'aide qui
viennent un autre programme est aussi
abordée par 60% florence l'été justement
civile douglas par l'équipe du docteur
styger en 2020 je sortais de traitement
d'une hospitalisation et combats
virtuels mais ça a été beaucoup
d'ajustements qui ça moi ça m'a affecté
aussi je faisais beaucoup trop
d'exercices ça pouvait être de 40 km par
jour de course - c'était
[Musique]
inhumain face à la vague le soutien en
virtuel permet d'un des plus grand
nombre de patients à domicile il redonne
à plusieurs les repères perdus avec la
pandémie le traitement des troubles
alimentaires peut être long on va sortir
d'une pandémie qui était à qui
atteignait la population niveau physique
qu'on veut sortir qui j'éprouve un
certain qu une société malade au niveau
de la santé mentale florence dit qu'elle
va mieux et je travaille en santé
mentale il sait que les besoins sont
grands ici elles nourrissent despatie
radio canada montréal